it seemed like this is a season where
everybody's going on a strike we know
what's going on with writers and actors
guilt we saw what UPS got big
negotiation and now the Union Auto
Workers 13 000 United Auto Workers went
on a strike after their union leaders
couldn't Bridge a massive gap between
themselves and the three top automakers
in America we're talking GM Ford and
stalantis AKA Chrysler a massive Gap
here's what it looks like GM and Ford it
offered 20 increase in their salary and
stalantis offered 17 and a half guess
what union leaders asked for no we want
a 36 percent increase studies are shown
right now that this could cost the
economy billions of dollars every day
while they're on a strike and on top of
that 50 000 jobs it is a mess folks but
I think they watch what's going on with
the strike with ups and they said hey
maybe we can get paid we're going to
talk about that today so if you get
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel let's
get right into it so what's really
happening these 13 000 Auto Workers go
on a strike break the strike began at a
General Motors Assembly Plant in
Wentzville Missouri a Ford factory in
Wayne Michigan near Detroit and a
stalantis g plant in Toledo Ohio it is
the first time in the Union's 88 year
history that these three different
companies were targeted simultaneously
so what are the Union's demands as I
told you earlier they want a 36 percent
wage increase over four years the union
is also asking restoration of cost of
living pay raises and and to varying
tiers of wages for factory jobs and you
ready on top of that they want to work
only four days they want to work 32
hours a week but they want to get paid
at 40 hours a week is what they're
asking for by the way Bernie Sanders
just said yesterday we ought to consider
going to a four-week model that's what
we ought to be thinking about doing so
guess what this Union is asking for
exactly that and on top of that the
restoration of traditional defined
benefit pensions for new hires who now
receive only 401K style retirement plans
pension increases for retirees and other
items so what are the auto Maker's
position GM and Fort as I said earlier
offer 20 increase stalantis Jeep
Chrysler offered 17 and a half percent
increased automakers say they're facing
unprecedented demands as they develop
and build new electric vehicles while at
the same time making gas powered cars
SUVs and trucks to pay the bills they're
worried labor costs will rise so much
that they'll have to price their cars
above those sold by Foreign automakers
with U.S factories which means who's
going to be paying a price for that you
the person buying the car so now what
are the potential impacts of the strike
the strike could push vehicle prices
higher and strain on the economy already
Brews by inflation also Wildcats may
even become a factor in next year's
presidential election testing Joe
Biden's commitment because he said no
presidential candidate has ever been
more pro-union than me so this could
pressure President Biden to come out and
have to defend these union leaders the
strike could also last longer than
previous work stoppages such as a 40-day
strike against GM in 2019. you ever
wonder why Jamie Diamond CEO of Chase
has a 900 million dollar art collection
or Steve Cohen 1.1 billion art
collection or Microsoft has nearly a
billion dollar collection the company 5
000 art pieces in 180 different
locations worldwide why because
billionaires and millionaires understand
one of the ways to hedge against
inflation money being printed market
crash interest rates is to buy
non-duplicatable assets and one of them
is Art Fine Arts and that's why today's
sponsor is Masterworks let me tell you a
little bit about Masterworks you may be
watching the same pad I'm not a
millionaire or a billion I can't afford
to buy Warhol or Banksy or Basquiat I'm
going to buy that well Masterworks
allows you to buy fractional shares like
buying a share of Apple you buy a share
of a Banksy painting or a Warhol piece
you're able to do that throw Masterworks
this is why over 800 000 people have
signed up with Masterworks offerings
have sold out within minutes and many of
you have already created accounts and
some of you that haven't this is your
chance to skip the waiting list and
start your collection today just click
on the link in the description go to
Masterworks Dot art forward slash value
team and once again Masterworks dot art
forward slash value timid or click on a
link below here's what we have to
consider don't forget that there is a
current a strike going on with Writers
Guild of America and actors writer
started in May this is why Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy Kimmel haven't done a show and
they started a podcast to get a call
that I think the strike force or
something like that and actors went on
strike in July nothing's been happening
Drew Barrymore wanted to bring back her
show she got destroyed by fans Bill
Maher was going to bring back he got
destroyed by fans imagine how long these
guys haven't been working that started
in May it's September already that's a
long time then you got UPS now you got
this to be looking at so we looked at it
and said hey our numbers for Unions
number of members for Union increasing
meaning are people wanting more Union in
private sector or they want to get away
from unions here's what the numbers look
like if you look at from 1972 till today
1972 24.2 percent of private sector
memberships they had unions today six
percent you know what America is saying
we don't like the union private sector
keep keep it on the public but stay away
from it in the private sector and if you
like Union go work for the public sector
not the private sector okay so what is
the impact on America because when you
think about these three automakers four
gmn you know Chrysler or stalantis what
percentage of the cars in America do
they produce 40 that's why this is a big
deal the strike is expected to lead to
production cuts at the big three
automakers which could lead to job
losses the strike is also expect to
disrupt the supply chain for the
automotive industry which could lead to
higher prices for cars and trucks now
here's also why this is bad news do you
remember during covet what was going on
with used car prices it's a twenty
thousand dollar car selling for thirty
eight thousand dollars what's going on
over here because they couldn't find the
cheapest remember sometimes even used
car prices were selling more than new
car prices some people are selling their
cars look at the chart right here this
is what it tells us on what's happened
with used car prices from 1960 to today
okay if you look at the chart to the top
right that's during covet it's not as if
prices are already skyrocketing every
other article you read what is the
average car payment is the most it's
ever been in history in America on top
of that add the strike with a 36 percent
demand that they're asking for not
realizing who's going to pay the price
for it the consumer you so now who is
UAW who's the United Auto Workers it's a
union that was founded in 1935 Walter
reuter who's a president of the Union
from 1946 till 1970 some 24 years two
times there was an attempted
assassination on him this guy Walter he
was so powerful at one point that John F
Kennedy sent him to go to Cuba to
negotiate for a hostage and on top of
that LBJ used them regularly for many
different things and when Nixon was
running Nixon called him the guy that
John F Kennedy would have never gotten
elected without this man he was so
powerful that even later on Bill Clinton
gave him a medal of honor I believe in
1995 this is a heavyweight like before
there was Jimmy Hoffa there was Walter
reuter they should make a movie about
this guy very interesting guy so the UAW
was instrumental in organizing in Auto
industry and winning major game for
workers such as higher wages better
benefits and safer working conditions it
was also involved in political activism
and supportive candidates who supported
labor unions so now the question becomes
imagine you're at a company you're for
your GM your stalantis you're having a
boardroom meeting with all your board
members and saying what can we do about
this 36 increase we offered them 20 we
offered them 70 17 and a half percent
one person says I think we need to let
go of 10 of our employees well that's
the old school of fixing this what do
you think Johnny one guy says 29 years
old just came out of MIT he says we need
to double down on robots and we need to
double down on AI what a great idea
what'll happen if we do that we can fire
half of our employees and we can still
build these cars without them and we
don't even need to deal with the unions
if we let them go that's not a bad idea
does anybody else agree with them Mary
over here that jumps in and says I do
too I went to work in business school
here's what I think I need to be doing
boom who ends up paying a price these
union leaders are fighting for these
people those people thinking these union
leaders are doing good for them are
going to be replaced by robots let me
give you some more crazy facts about
about what this could possibly impact
the strike is expected to cost the big
three automakers billions of dollars in
Revenue now people on the other side
will say they can afford it look how
much profit they're making it's on the
backs of the labor it's on the backs of
all these people they can't afford to
give a 36 raise when companies like this
lose billions of dollars the way they
get that money back is through You by
raising their prices that's what they do
that's how basic economy works and
capitalism works on top of that GM Ford
and stalantis announced idle plants in
the U.S and Canada the strike has also
led to the cancellation of shift at many
other Automotive plans so what could be
some of the possible outcomes with this
strike because it just happened the 15th
of September right so let's take a look
one a quick settlement the UAW and the
big three automakers could reach a quick
settlement ending the strike within days
if not weeks this would be the best case
scenario for both sides as it would
minimize the economic damage caused by
the strike number two a long and
protracted strike number three a strike
that ends in a lockout The Big Three
automakers could lock out the UAW
workers forcing them to return to work
without a new contract this would be a
major victory for the automakers but it
would also be a major setback for the
UAW and its members number four a strike
that ends in a strike breaking the
automakers could hire replacement
workers to break the strike this would
be a last resort for automakers as it
would be highly disruptive and could
damage their reputations and last but
not least a strike that ends in a
government intervention and remember
this is possible because President Biden
claimed he is the biggest pro-union
president of all time the federal
government could intervene in a strike
either by mediating a settlement or by
taking other steps to end the strike
this is a possibility but it is unlikely
as the government has traditionally been
reluctant to intervene in labor disputes
so so here's some of the factors that
could influence the outcome of this
strike number one the bargaining
position of the two sides the UAW and
the big three automakers have different
goals in the negotiation UAW is seeking
higher wages better benefits and Shop
security for its members The Big Three
are seeking to reduce costs and improve
their competitiveness the bargaining
position of the two sides will be a
major factor in determining the outcome
of the strike number two the level of
public support for the strike the
Public's perception of the strike will
also be a factor in the outcome if the
public supports the strike it will put
pressure on the automakers to reach a
settlement if the public opposes the
strike it will make it more difficult
for the UAW to win its demands and last
but not least the intervention of the
federal government as we talked about
earlier so you know what's a great thing
about this sometimes because you know we
did a case study on you know Social
Security didn't work well it was only
supposed to help a couple thousand
people now will realize that we can't
afford Social Security we can't afford
Medicare we can't afford many of these
different programs the entitlement
programs we cannot afford it and people
are starting to realize America is
getting more and more and more in debt
we've tested unions how have they worked
they start off very coming from a place
of wanting to help you out do you know
what union leaders in-laws and lawyers
have in common let me explain lawyers
when a husband and wife is sitting there
happily married say they want to set up
a nuptial agreement or prenuptial
agreement lawyers come in husband and
wife we love each other we just kind of
want to put this in place that in case
something happens later on in life we're
protected she's protective we're all
protect right no problem you know what
the lawyer's job is to make more money
to create feud between the two spouses
her lawyer and his lawyer are actually
on the same page they're on the same
team not their team they're not
representing the spouse and this one
over here they sit there and say let's
create a fight let's create another 20
hours of fees times 500 bucks so let's
create a little bit of division I don't
think that's fair she should get more I
don't think that's for he should get
more and the wife is like yes he's right
I should get the miles so I work my ass
off 22 years for those models executive
no but it's not fair so and then all of
a sudden two weeks later here's a bill
how much thirteen thousand eight hundred
dollars it was only supposed to cost
three thousand dollars because they know
what they wanted what do in-laws do you
know what I I noticed your husband he
doesn't work as hard as such and such as
husband did you notice your sister's
husband works very hard he doesn't work
that hard and if I was you and if I
would make him do this and the next
thing you know the husband comes home
what does that daughter do the
daughter's like you don't work as hard
as Mary's husband and you know and the
husband's like what the f just happened
right now my eyes came from work what
are you talking about right now well
that's because you're not a good husband
I'm confused right now what he doesn't
realize is there was an instigator a
union leader called an in-law you know
how I noticed I was a kid and I watched
my parents go through two divorces when
the in-laws were the union leaders so
you know what the union leaders do here
we go we're here to protect the
employees we're here for you
the union leaders for only a little
membership that you pay every month but
we're here for you really yeah we're
here for you and writers we're here for
you do they haven't worked for four
months but we're here for you make sure
you pay your membership but we're here
for you and by the way we can't work and
do anything else but we're here for you
you're talking about here you know we're
starting to realize who pays the price
the employee the consumer everybody pays
the price and you know who wins the
union wins and based on the membership
we're seeing more and more people are
saying go help public
we don't want a part of Union men we
appreciate your help we're going to
figure out how we're going to make our
relationships work we're going to figure
out how we the employees and the
employers are going to get along because
if Ford doesn't take care of us we'll go
to GM if GM doesn't take care of us
we'll go to you know Jeep Chrysler if
they don't take curves we'll go to Tesla
that's what competition is for and
people go to a different place at the
end of the day capitalism wins
competition wins and the people that are
willing to improve and offer better
opportunity that's what ends up winning
so if you got value out of this video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel if you're arguing debating with
your relatives even better that's the
purpose it is keep debating the points
and see who makes the best point but if
you want to watch another video on
unions to fall in love with unions even
more we did a video on unions what these
Writers Guild and Actors Guild are doing
if you've never seen a click here to
watch so take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]